[Music]
he's I rate about the Golden State and
he's here once again to set the record
straight please welcome the great actor
comedian and podcaster Adam
Corolla all
right we got a lot of cover so we got a
couple of stories let's get right to it
the first one is a new study finds that
California has the worst bullying
problem in the United States beating out
Alaska Nevada and new J New Jersey it
beats out New Jersey Adam what the
hell's going on in
California well we may have a different
standard of buling than New Jersey and
Alaska because miss gendering somebody
uh not using their pronouns
complimenting a female on an outfit
she's wearing these are all buling
offenses in
California not so much in Alaska and New
Jersey so maybe it's just we we have so
many potential bullying offenses in
California yeah that makes sense that
makes sense I long for the old bullies
you know the kind that would give you a
Melvin or a a wedgie a
swirly I I was one of the people that
actually enjoyed those
things you the the bullet I know I I I I
wish someone would give me a wedgie at
this point in in my life in my career
yeah um but really the people my kids
were bullied by Gavin Newsome because he
closed all the schools and then the
teachers unions bullied my kids by
screaming at them to pull up a a a mask
a paper mask every 10 seconds in masking
up in between bites I mean actually they
are being bullied but they're being
bullied by the teachers unions and the
governor you know speaking of the
governor he signed a new law I believe
it's Banning willful Defiance suspension
ions for middle and high school students
meaning kids can't get suspended for
stuff like breaking the dress code
talking back to their teacher or using
phones in class is this just more G bad
governing from Gavin how's this guy
gonna run for
president I I have no idea but this is
what the left does kids are failing in
school so they change the MTH score so
it's a reverse engineering that doesn't
work so you go it's like saying we have
a childhood obesity problem well then
get rid of the scales
yes that's true if you get rid of books
then you never know that the kids are
illiterate right I'm going to do that
but it's it's really it's it's it's it's
a serious mindset issue that Gavin
Newsome has which is there's too much
prostitution than legalized prostitution
there's too many black and brown people
in prison then don't arrest black and
brown prison and put them in prison I
mean if you really think about it it's a
it's like saying my car is such a pile
of junk it won't go faster than 30 m
hour on the freeway well break the glass
and turn the speedometer needle up to 70
M an hour and then you'll be fine what
are teachers going to do if kids can't
behave oh I I don't know I would drink
heavily if I work for Unified School
District I I would have a tap installed
at my
desk and
and when I was out when the keg was
spent I put a dunce cap on it that's how
you know the last topic here San
Francisco is getting its first drag
school which will apparently teach the
fundamentals of drag performance and the
history of drag see I think this is a
good idea because it's finally a
business is moving into San
Francisco it's the only School Asians
aren't excelling
in they beat the crap out of us in every
measurable academic subject except for
drag so give it time Adam give it time
the uh Asians always Excel they'll be on
top of drag better than
anybody all right Adam where San
Francisco is awesome yeah it go in there
learn how to tuck your junk and then be
beat up by a junkie as soon as you walk
out of the school hey where can people
uh find your podcast more about your
tour
dates oh you can go to adamcarolla.com
and hear my daily podcast there and you
can see me coming up in Spokane and
Tacoma October 29th I should say 27th
through the 29th but just go to adam.com
all the live dates are there and I'm
playing all over the country thank you
Adam always a pleasure see you
soon up next people hearts are aching
over a dog that was
record-breaking
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else